MELISSA: Please welcome
Ken Jennings.
KEN JENNINGS: Thanks, Melissa.
Well, thank you all
for coming out.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I flew out from Seattle
just to see you guys.
It's not a big tech town.
So it's exciting to be someplace
with a few software
engineers for a change.
Post-Jeopardy.
I'm now an author pretty
much full time.
I was a software engineer
before, but
not a very good one.
Unlike, I'm sure, anybody who
gets hired at Google.
So I'm much happier in my second
life as a freelance
writer, where I can work from
home in my pajamas.
And the book that I have out
today, I guess sort of has
something to do with the
modern information age.
It's called "Because I Said So!"
The idea is to debunk or
possibly prove all these cliches
that parents are
always harassing their kids
with, don't go swimming until
half an hour after you eat; or
don't pop your knuckles,
you'll get arthritis; or don't
swallow watermelon seeds,
it'll sprout in your stomach
and you'll die.
We don't all hear all
of these as kids.
But speaking only for myself, I
know my parents were always
threatening us with dire things
that would happen if we
did any of these behaviors that
really seemed sort of
harmless to us.
And I realize now that I have
kids, that I was starting to
do the same thing.
I have a 10-year-old boy and a
6-year-old girl and I realize
that when you're a parent, I
guess I'm now aware of this,
you lie all the time.
You have to.
You have to lie all the time.
And the lies are
not malicious.
They're in fact, quite
the opposite.
You feel like it's a benevolent
lie to tell your
kids that Santa is going to
bring them presents if they're
good, or that their hamster
actually went to live on
grandpa's farm, or that
really you love them
both exactly the same.
I feel like these are pretty
useful lies actually.
There's some utility to this.
But often I would find myself
lying out of more
self-serving reasons.
Just because I felt like
I had to be confident.
I couldn't show any
sign of weakness.
Kids are like bears, I guess.
If your kid asks you, really?
You to say yes, that's right.
Do what you're told.
Finish your vegetables.
And more and more often
I realized--
in fact, I know when
it occurred to me.
This is how the book starts.
My son comes careening into--
we're in my parents' house.
My son comes careening around
the corner in the
kitchen with a--
kids, if there's some place in
the house where they can run
in a circle, they'll do it.
I don't know why.
He comes running in
with a Tootsie Pop
sticking out of his mouth.
And I'm like whoa, whoa,
whoa, slow down.
Like what if you fell?
That lollipop could like go
through the back of your soft
palate in the back of
your mouth and like
jab you in the brain.
And he was an eight-year-old
boy, so of course he's
fascinated.
Like this doesn't scare him.
This is like, really?
Is that true?
Could that really happen?
And I realized when he
asked that, I had no
idea if that was true.
Like I have done research
on oral trauma?
No.
Like, I have no idea.
I'm just repeating some thing
that my mom randomly told me
in the late '70s, probably on
the basis of no information as
well, and assuming it's
going to be correct.
And luckily, we're at
my mom's house.
So I asked her.
I was like, is this true?
You always used to
tell us that.
And she was like, oh,
I don't know.
That's just something grandma
used to tell us.
I think it happens in
a Chaim Potok novel.
So this is how I'm disappointing
my kids.
Based on my mind vaguely
remembered notions of my mom's
hazily remembered memory
of a Chaim Potok novel?
Like I understand he's a rabbi
as well as a novelist, but
maybe this is not how I
should be choosing the
things I tell my kids.
And I realized these things do
sort of, just sort of turn up
cyclically.
Like I'm sure when my son has
kids, now he's going to tell
them don't run with a Tootsie
Pop in your mouth.
It'll give your brain
damage if you fall.
And again, he will
have no idea.
And I thought, well
maybe there's a--
I'm sort of a full-time
trivia author now.
Somehow I'm in this weird niche,
thanks to Alex Trebek.
Like maybe there's
a book in this.
So I started gathering these
myths, gathering from memory
my own childhood.
What did my parents tell me?
Don't eat the cookie dough.
You'll get worms.
Don't run outside.
I guess worms were very
big in the late '70s.
Like no matter what it
was, we'd get worms.
And every time I saw a friend,
I'd ask them, hey, what were
these cliches that your
parents were always
threatening you with?
I want to see if these things
are actually true.
And one person would remember
their mom said that you lose
10% of your body heat
through your head.
Or somebody else would remember
their dad saying that
if you swallow gum, it'll sit in
your stomach undigested for
seven years.
And he was fascinated by that.
And so I started there.
I started to collect a little
spreadsheet of these things.
And I was getting close
to having enough for a
book, and not quite.
So I did what I'm sure any of
you would do and I had Reddit
crowd-source the rest
of this for me.
Hey Reddit, what are some
of the weird things your
parents told you?
P.S., write my book for me.
And in with all the goofy bacon
jokes and screeds about
marijuana legalization, a lot
of people suggested great
parental cliches that I had
not thought of, that were
really, really good
fits for the book.
And I started to research
these things.
And it turned out that
surprisingly, maybe I'm
jumping the gun a little here,
but surprisingly there's
actually a lot of
good scientific
research on some of these.
I guess enough kids were told
that there's a five-second
rule between when you drop food
and when you can pick it
up in the shopping mall food
court, enough kids are told
this, that many of them
have gone to college.
And there are now four or five
good academic studies on
whether or not the five-second
rule exists.
Spoilers, it doesn't.
Food gets contaminated when
it lands on something.
So if you drop it and there
is rat poison or bleach or
salmonella or something on the
floor, it's contaminated then.
You don't get some magical
window where the microbes
wait, three, four, five, go.
But by the same token, they
can only get these results
when they pretreat the floor
with salmonella.
When they do that, the food
comes back contaminated.
Every time they run these
experiments on regular dorm
cafeteria floors, it's
perfectly fine.
And in many cases, a surprising
number of these
were coming back false, which
is what I wanted.
The book is no good if all
these things are true.
And by the same token, there
were some selection bias.
Obviously if something turns out
to be surprisingly false,
in the book it goes.
I found out that that thing your
parents told you about
having to drink eight glasses
of water a day, it's bogus.
It's actually dangerous.
It's possible to over hydrate
your brain and people have
died from this.
Whereas, the body's thirst
mechanism actually kicks in
long before dehydration.
So you're actually good just
drinking water when you're
thirsty and not trying to get to
some number that was forced
on you by a seventh grade
home ec teacher.
But there was some
selection bias.
Obviously, I would pick
the ones that were
interesting to debunk.
If it turns out that it really
is good advice to not play in
the street, that was
a less interesting
section in the book.
Here's sort of one sample entry
that I'll read, which I
already mentioned, about
swallowed gum sitting in your
stomach undigested
for seven years.
It's just a threat if you
swallow your gum.
Did you guys hear this as
kids or is just me?
My parents were firm
believers in this.
So from the book, could
this really be true?
If I swallow a piece of gum
today, will it really emerge
Rip van Winkle-like into some
futuristic Japanese-style
toilet in the year 2020?
Is there a possibility that
tonight I will poop the piece
of gum that I accidentally
swallowed during "Big Momma's
House 2?"
When pondering these questions
with my friend Raj, he
remembered that as a child, he
wondered what would happen if
he swallowed two
pieces of gum?
Would they be trapped for
seven years or 14?
In other words, would they
serve their sentences
consecutively or concurrently?
I hate to pop your bubble, but
the answer is neither.
Swallowed gum routinely gets
furloughed within 24 hours,
like a diplomat or a Kennedy.
It's true that about a quarter
of chewing gum is the gum base
itself, a completely food-free
substance made up of latexes,
resins, waxes, and
emulsifiers.
Your gastrointestinal tract
could work on that for seven
years and have no luck
digesting it.
But that's not what happens.
Quote "That would mean that
every single person who ever
swallowed gum within the last
seven years would have
evidence of the gum in their
digestive tract," Dr. David
Milov told "Scientific
American." "On occasion, we'll
see a piece of swallowed
gum in a colonoscopy.
But usually, it's not something
that's any more than
a week old." Your intestine
eliminates gum the same way it
eliminates half-chewed corn
kernels and anything else
that's too tough to digest,
out the rectum
within a day or two.
I guess I didn't realize people
were going to be eating
lunch during this.
I apologize in advance,
especially for the thing
that's about to happen
in two paragraphs.
If you're almost there, you
may want to finish up.
However, Dr. Milov also led the
team that published the
landmark study, "Chewing
Gum Bezoars of the
Gastrointestinal Tract," in a
1998 issue of the medical
journal "Pediatrics." A
"bezoar": is a clump of
undigested stuff that
gets trapped in
the stomach or intestine.
The wonderful name comes from
the Persian word for antidote,
since animal bezoars, sort of
like those owl pellets you had
to dissect in eighth grade, were
anciently thought to have
remarkable health properties.
Most bezoars are boluses
of food or pills.
Sometimes in rare cases
of Rapunzel syndrome,
they're made of--
anyone?
AUDIENCE: Hair.
KEN JENNINGS: Swallowed
hair, ugh.
And sometimes, very rarely,
they can be
made of chewing gum.
Dr. Milov's team found three
cases of young children whose,
this is a quote from the report,
"means of discarding
their gum (swallowing) was well
known to the families and
was a source of levity." Well,
nobody was laughing when the
gum swallowing led to chronic
constipation and, finally,
surgery when laxatives
proved powerless.
If you want your kids to quit
swallowing their gum, here's
the money quote.
"This clean-out regimen produced
no results after four
days." In other words,
the laxatives.
"On the fifth day, the child
was brought in for manual
disimpaction under conscious
sedation and rectal suction
biopsy." On removal of the--
here's the money quote, "On
removal of the leading edge of
the fecoma, a taffy-like trail
of fecal material remained
in the rectum.
The mass was eventually manually
withdrawn and was
primarily made up
of chewing gum."
Wow, I hope these parents kept
the rectal suction biopsy
video on hand to show
future prom dates.
But keep in mind, this was a kid
who was swallowing five to
seven pieces of gum per day.
Other cases only got serious
when stuff like coins got
swallowed and trapping in the
Wrigley's brand butt plug.
So don't worry, the occasional
accidentally swallowed piece
of gum isn't going
to do any harm.
You'd have to be the Hunter S.
Thompson of gum swallowing to
get into medical trouble.
But prepare to be embarrassed,
if you're caught.
Dr. Milov writes that, quote,
"The rainbow of fused
multicolored gum fragments in
the removed fecoma is easily
recognized by physician and
family as old gum." In the
end, maybe I'm just weird that
that actually sounds sort of
beautiful, other than the part
where it gets pulled out of
somebody's butt.
And then the verdict is false.
All the myths and the cliches
in the book are given a
verdict on the scale
of true to false.
And many of them do fall
somewhere in the middle.
Some of them are true with a
nyeh, false with a-- but.
On some of them, the research
is ongoing.
For many years, for example,
researchers were pretty sure
that cold weather did nothing
to make people
susceptible to colds.
They knew that there
was a cold season.
But there's still not widespread
agreement on what
causes that.
Is it just people packed indoors
together during the
winter, sharing germs?
Is it because school
is in session?
Is it because the cold
lowers your immunity?
Is it because the virus does
better in cold conditions?
Nobody is 100% sure.
They were pretty sure it
wasn't temperature.
Because they would dab infected
mucus on people--
again, sorry if you're eating--
on people's noses, at
different temperatures.
And they would find no
relationship between who got a
cold and who was cold.
But there's some new research
out of a university in Wales,
where they tried to model how
people catch colds in a more
organic way.
During cold season, they would
have people sit in a lab, with
their feet in buckets of cold
water, and then compare who
caught a cold, just in the next
month of running around
Wales, to the control group
that was not sitting with
their feet in cold water.
And they found a pretty
strong causal link.
Something about having cold
feet actually made these
people catch colds.
So as crazy as it sounds,
your mom was right.
These people might be catching
cold because they didn't put
on galoshes, or because they
went outside with wet hair, or
all the things your mom
was freaked about.
So I think there is some comfort
here for parents who--
there is some vindication for
parents who have been saying
that breakfast is the
most important meal
of the day or whatever.
Some of these things are true.
But the vast majority are not.
And that's trouble
in our house.
My son read a galley, an
early copy of the book.
And now he is way
over-informed.
It's gotten to the point where
my wife will be like, Dylan,
you're sitting to
close to the TV.
Get back on the couch.
And he won't even look up.
He'll be like, no I'm not.
Dad says it's fine.
It's just temporary
eye strain.
I think this is hilarious.
If my wife were here, I don't
think she's such a fan.
And you realize what
the utility is to a
lot of these myths.
Not only does it make the
parent look wise and
authoritative, oftentimes I am
sure these things arise out of
the need to--
you want to shut down some
annoying behavior.
You don't want your kids
popping their knuckles,
because if you hear that sound
one more time, you're going to
go crash the car or something.
And so you tell your kid
that causes arthritis.
And it's not really true.
But kids fall for
a lot of this.
And I'm sort of concerned that
one effect of this might be
that as these parental paranoias
sort of accumulate
over generations, that we sort
of forget how they started.
That they started as
well-intended ways of
protecting your kids.
And we start to think there is
some terrible threat if your
child swallows a watermelon
seed, or picks up a dirty
feather at the playground, or
looks at the microwave while
it's running, or whatever
these things are.
Writes on his skin with
a ballpoint pen.
I had a seventh grade biology
teacher freak out because I
was drawing something on my hand
with a pen and that was
going to cause cancer
or something.
And over time, you get this
gradual accumulation of these
parental paranoias.
And the result is our kids start
getting more and more
cushioned, more and more
bubble-wrapped for any kind of
experimentation or fun.
And before long, you get the
kind of helicopter parents you
read about in scary "Time"
magazine cover packages of
these parents who never let
their kids do any of the
things that--
I got to ride my bike
to school as a kid.
But no, you can't
do that today.
Kids who can't climb trees.
You see crazy examples.
I read a "Dear Abby" column,
where she told parents to take
a picture of their kids every
day leaving the house in that
day's clothes, because that
way if they got kidnapped,
she's got something to
show to the cops.
This is like a serious
well-intended solution.
Or--
this is great.
I've actually heard about
universities that now have
sort of mommy cams in the dorms
so that your mom can
like keep an eye on what's
going on in the
old residence hall.
Companies are preparing parent
packets, like big accounting
companies are now preparing
parent packets for their new
job interviews every year
because often a concerned mom
or dad will come along.
And so I'm sort of worried
that in our well-intended
desire to keep our kids safe,
we're actually making kids
unhappy, unable to cope with the
modern world, unconfident
about the modern world.
The perfect example is like
don't talk to strangers.
What could be a less
controversial piece of advice?
And of course, your kids
shouldn't talk to strangers.
Actually if you talk to child
safety advocacy groups now,
they say that's like the worst
thing you could say.
Never tell your kid not
to talk to strangers.
Kids don't understand that.
It just makes them insecure
about adults.
There have been cases where a
kid got lost and then tried to
hide from all the people that
were looking for him because
they were strangers.
And instead, they say what
you need to do is
teach kids to be confident.
If they get in that kind of
situation, they need to know
which adults they should
be looking to for help.
Go to somebody in uniform.
Go to somebody who works
for the store.
Try to find another
mom with kids.
There's actually good, practical
advice you can give
kids that doesn't scare them.
And instead, we've created
this whole industry based
around stranger danger.
This idea that some creepy guy
in a white van is going to
grab your kid, when really the
idea of a stranger kidnapping
a kid is something that only
happens like on the order of a
few dozen times every year
in this country.
Most of the, a child vanishes
every n minutes, stats you
hear, it's all people the
family know, it's a
noncustodial parent
or something.
But it's how we create
the method
of this random kidnapper.
So hopefully, actually debunking
some of these things
will let parents breathe a
little easier and let their
kids be kids.
The cool thing about writing
this book today is it's
actually possible to
be written today.
We live in an age where
information is much more
available to the lay
person, public
interest writer like me.
If I don't know whether or not
apple seeds are poisonous, I
can Bing it.
I'm just kidding.
I would google it.
When I was a kid, I was sort of
a trivia nerd kid you'll be
shocked to hear, when I was
10 or 11 years old.
We did not have Google.
We lived in this strange
internet-free world where the
real scoop on myths like this,
if they got delivered at all,
came in the forms of often out
of print paperbacks that you'd
have to find in a
used bookstore.
And I remember knowing, to this
day I know which of these
books held which things.
I know that back before the
internet, if you wanted to
know a best guess as to what the
secret herbs and spices in
the Colonel's chicken was,
that's in a book called "Big
Secrets" by William
Poundstone.
And if you want to know the
scoop about the fact that in
Columbus's day, nobody really
thought the world was flat,
contrary to popular belief.
That was in Tom Burnam's book,
"The Dictionary of
Misinformation."
There were all these sort of
pop reference books where
people knew this stuff.
Of course today, we
don't need that.
All this kind of stuff
is well handled
by Snopes, by Wikipedia.
It's well-indexed by Google.
All this stuff should just
be a click away.
And the experience of fighting
and getting my ass kicked by
Watson sort of made me think
what are the implications of
living in this world where
our search engines or our
smartphones can do lots of our
stuff remembering stuff for
us, a lot of our stuff
remembering for us?
I realized after losing
to Google--
or to Google, Freudian slip,
after losing to Watson, I'm
someone who always drew a lot
of I guess self-esteem from
being the guy who's good
at remembering stuff.
It used to be a valuable thing
in the workplace to know who's
the person in the office you go
to when you can't remember
the name of the bassist
of in that band?
Or what's the name of
that character actor
on that one TV show?
And I was always that guy, at
school, or in the dorms, or in
the office.
And today, nobody
needs that guy.
That guy is out of work.
If you don't remember the name
of some guy, you look it up on
your phone.
And it's super easy.
And in effect, when I lost to
Watson, I sort of felt like
the first person in America
who'd lost his job to this new
generation of thinking machine,
just like a 1970s
Detroit factory worker getting
pushed off the assembly line
by the robot that can do his
job much faster and more
reliably than him.
And I felt like I was the first
one of those guys for
the information age, which
was a great honor.
And the more I read up on this,
I feel like I'm not
going to be the last one.
There's lots of other
sort of--
I don't want say menial, but
sort of low-level information
gathering jobs where Watson or
technologies like it are
becoming very good.
I'm sure there are probably
people in this room working on
these technologies.
Pharmacists, almost all that
job can be automated.
In fact, lots of medical kinds
of lab work and diagnosis is
now getting to the point where
it can be automated.
IBM has been very clear
that Watson is going
into health care now.
I assume that's less
controversial than Homeland
Security or something.
Really, our mass information
collecting and processing
software, it's just going
to cure cancer.
Don't worry about government
contracts at all.
And paralegals, for example.
There's lots of jobs where
people doing low-level
information collection that
really a pretty short Shell
script could probably do
your job now, sir.
And what does that
mean for us?
What does that mean in a world
where we don't have to know
stuff anymore?
What's going to happen
our brains?
The book I wrote before this was
called "Maphead." It was
about my love of maps
and geography.
There's a chapter on--
anybody here from Google Geo?
There's like a whole chapter
on Google, ayeh.
There's a whole chapter on
the new digital mapping
technologies and what
that means for us.
And I talked to quite a few
researchers in the book, who
sort of felt like the new maps
have the potential to be a new
golden age for mapping.
There's also the downside of
what GPS is doing to us.
If we outsource the part of our
brain that navigates and
does sense of direction to a
little talking voice on our
dashboard, this is the reason
why you always read in the
paper about people driving into
lakes and driving onto
railroad tracks.
They just obey the little
talking voice.
How I was supposed to know
that was a lake?
It's like how we all used
to be able to--
15 years ago, we were all really
good at memorizing
seven digit numbers.
And now like, I don't even know
my phone number because
there's no use for it anymore.
So what if our phones and our
search engines can do
all this for us?
I hope that our ability to
remember facts doesn't atrophy
in the same way that our ability
to remember phone
numbers and our ability to not
drive into lakes has sort of
changed in the past few years.
I believe there is still some
utility to knowing a fact off
the top of your head.
We were actually talking
about this earlier.
It's great that when there's
something on the tip of our
tongue that we don't know, thank
goodness we can google.
And it's not just
idle curiosity.
Often that Google search might
be for something more urgent.
But imagine what it means to
us that we know facts.
What does that do for us?
In education, I guess now
there's sort of an emphasis on
knowing how to think rather than
knowing what to think.
There's less of an emphasis on
making sure that kids are
chock-full of dates and
so forth, dates and
formulas, and what not.
Because ahh, they can
look that up.
I think there is still virtue
in knowing facts.
If there are two advantages to
knowing something off the top
your head versus having to whip
out your phone or on your
console, I would say it's
probably the advantage of
scale and the advantage
of time.
The first is an advantage
of volume.
The fact that we live in a
information age means that
it's easier to get a hold
of information.
It also means there's
exponentially more information
coming at us at all times.
Sure, there have been great
Renaissance men in history,
Thomas Jefferson, and Ben
Franklin, Leonardo da Vinci.
But notice how they lived sort
of close to the Renaissance.
There was a lot less
to know back then.
You put Jefferson on "Jeopardy"
today, and he's
really going to be struggling
at nuclear physics or '70s
sit-coms, or hip-hop.
I mean he's going to get
his butt kicked.
There's just more to know more,
more to know today than
there was for the guy in the
16th century or the 18th
century, who could
know everything.
And it's global.
My vacation plans could get
affected by a volcano in
Iceland, or on the darker side,
a terrorist cell in
Pakistan, or the
Greek economy.
Little things happening a world
away, can really affect
my day-to-day life, in a world
that wasn't true in Leonardo's
time or in Jefferson's time.
And to make good decisions based
on all these facts, we
need to synthesize them.
And that only happens when we
have these facts, I believe,
at our fingertips.
Let's say I'm trying
to decide--
we'll go back in time a month.
I'll trying to decide
who to vote for.
I learned already, my map work,
that less than a quarter
of Americans can find Iraq
and Afghanistan on a map.
It's closer to 10%.
Ladies and gentlemen, this
is who's voting on
your foreign policy.
And it strikes me that for me
to even make a well-informed
decision as a citizen on which
candidate I'm going to vote
for in that arena, I should
know more than that.
Not only should I know the
relative locations of Iraq and
Afghanistan, I should have some
idea of what I think the
conditions are there, what I
think the right plan is going
forward, and so forth.
And that's true not just for
foreign policy, but for dozens
of other arenas as well.
And if I am literally going to
sit there and have to goggle
every one of those questions
before I vote,
we know what happens.
People don't sit there and
google thousands of questions
before they fill out
their ballot.
They just end up doing a really
half-assed job, based
on really poor knowledge.
Whereas I believe if more of
those facts were literally in
their heads, those would be
the building block to more
informed decisions
on a daily basis.
Not just voting, but better
informed decisions about where
to go to eat, or what's quickest
way to drive from
here to there, or what should
my major be, should I
interview here or there?
The decisions we make fairly
regularly, but can have a big
effect on our lives.
The other advantage I would say
to knowing stuff in our
heads versus on our phones would
be an advantage of time.
The story I always think of here
is a little British girl.
She's about 10 years old.
So that would be the
fourth grade.
Do they have that there?
Well, what would be a fourth
grader in our system, on
vacation with her parents,
in Thailand.
She is at the beach one
day with her parents.
And she comes running up in the
morning and says, mom and
dad, I think we should
get off the beach.
And I'm like, what
do you mean?
We just got here.
And she said well,
look out to sea.
The level of the tide has
gone down quite a bit.
The tide's gone way out
since we've been here.
And now there's starting to be
like big, churning waves and
bubbles further out to sea.
And their parents are like,
what does that mean?
And she said well, we just
learned two weeks ago and Mr.
Kurney's geography class,
this is the
first sign of a tsunami.
This is what you see before
the wave hits.
And their parents are
like, are you sure?
Like are you saying there's
going to be a tsunami?
And she's like, that's
what we learned.
And somehow this little girl
convinces her parents that
this really is a early warning
sign of a tsunami.
So they get off the beach.
They tell the life guard.
The life guard clears
the beach.
And within less than an hour,
sure enough, the beach is
under water.
This was the day after
Christmas, 2006.
Is that right?
The big--
2005?
When was the big Boxing Day
tsunami on the Indian Ocean?
AUDIENCE: 2004.
KEN JENNINGS: 2004.
And this girl literally saved a
hundred lives by remembering
the right fact from her
geography teacher, at the
right time.
You know, one fact, well
deployed, in the right place
and at the right time,
was all it took.
Most of the examples are not
going to be so dramatic.
But I still believe that that's
true in general, that
one fact, well deployed, in the
right place, does have the
ability to change lives.
And thank goodness, in our
generation we have tools that
are just revolutionizing
the way we can
retrieve these facts.
But I also feel like we need
to have them on hand.
We need to not outsource the
part of our brain that knows
stuff, to our devices, no matter
how user friendly they
are, how amazing their holiday
doodles, the level of snacks
in their cafeteria.
As much I love Google, I hope
that we still know things and
it becomes a tool and not a
replacement for our memories.
I wanted to take questions
because I know we have a
little bit of time left over
and I didn't know if I was
going to cover what people
were interested in.
So if you have questions about
whatever, books, information
in general, Watson, "Jeopardy,"
feel free.
If you'd use one of these mics
at the side, that helps with
the sound I guess.
Because this is all being taped
for posterity and Watson
is watching us right now.
So yes, please feel free
to step up to a mic
if you have a question.
I feel like a shareholders'
meeting.
AUDIENCE: Greetings.
Do you know any cheesy computer
science jokes?
KEN JENNINGS: Ha, ha, ha.
Cheesy computer science jokes,
wow, I feel like I did.
The joke I always think of now
is the joke that made me
switch to computer science.
Which is, what's the difference
between an English
major and a large
pepperoni pizza?
At least the pizza can feed
a family of four.
I was an English major who got
a second degree in computer
science, pretty much on the
strength of that joke.
And now, I'm a writer.
I don't know.
Do you have a great tech joke
you want to share here?
AUDIENCE: I'll share
my favorite one.
Eight bytes walk into a bar.
They go up to the bartender
and say, make us a double.
KEN JENNINGS: Man,
that would kill.
You've got to take that
to the clubs.
That is a pretty good joke.
Thank you.
That was better than my joke.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Given what you just
talked about in terms of like,
I completely with you, you've
got to still know facts.
You got to have stuff at
the tip of your tongue.
Do you still think a show
like "Jeopardy" is
relevant and useful?
KEN JENNINGS: Yeah.
I was sort of wondering if
I should get into that.
Obviously, "Jeopardy" had to
answer that question many
times during the Watson games.
And they would always say,
no, no, "Jeopardy," fact
remembering is still
a very human task.
And people still watch the
Olympics, even though a car
can go faster than a sprinter
and has for a long
time, and so forth.
And I guess it's a good point.
I'm sure computers have been
able to play "Wheel of
Fortune" at near grandmaster
levels for many years now.
And yet, we all still
love Wheel.
But I actually do sort
I wonder that.
As it becomes less remarkable
to know where it stops just
because nobody needs to
anymore, what happens?
Does it become more remarkable
that there weirdos like me who
could do know all the presidents
in order or does it
just become sort of old-timey
and weird, like those people
that watch railroad trains go
by at particular times?
Like why do you have that hobby
that my grandpa had?
I honestly don't know which
way it's going to go.
I hope that there remains
something heroic about the
nation's proud know-it-alls and
that you will bear us on
litters to your feasts
in an age when nobody
knows anything anymore.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for the talk.
That was great.
I have your almanac,
which I love.
I actually host a quiz night
and I've ripped off or
borrowed lots of
ideas from it.
Just wondering if you have any
ideas for tomorrow night's
quiz that I'm hosting?
KEN JENNINGS: Ideas for tomorrow
night's-- like you
want a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What have you got, rounds,
questions?
KEN JENNINGS: I have talked to
lots of pub trivia guys who
use that book.
And I always sort of worried
because I'm sure somebody in
your audience might have
that book too.
AUDIENCE: They do.
But there's so much in
it, you'd never be
able memorize it all.
KEN JENNINGS: It does have
over 9,000 questions.
But remember who you're
dealing with.
I'm trying to think if there's
something great I just heard.
The funny thing is when I hear
a great piece of trivia, I
immediately have like a thing
in my phone for it because I
write a few trivia things.
And I want to make
sure I use them.
This was pretty good.
I just heard this.
In that new movie, what's
it called, "Rise of the
Guardians," where like Santa
Claus, and the Easter Bunny,
and the Tooth Fairy all gang up
to fight crime or whatever
it is they did.
So Santa has two words tattooed
on his two biceps, in
the vein of the love
and hate guy.
What are the two words
on Santa's biceps?
AUDIENCE: Naughty and nice.
KEN JENNINGS: Naughty
and nice, very good.
AUDIENCE: That's a good one.
KEN JENNINGS: Feel free.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question is related to what
you were talking about earlier
with knowing facts.
I got into a discussion with
someone recently where they
were saying that there's no
point in us knowing, an
average person knowing about
current political affairs
going on in China or just things
like that, that aren't
directly related to
our daily life.
I was wondering what your
thoughts were on that?
KEN JENNINGS: I guess I
don't really buy that
argument any more.
Maybe that was true 50 years
ago, that nothing happening a
world away could really affect
your life that much.
But I think we've seen
so many examples of
how that's not true.
I had to cancel a vacation a
couple years ago because of
the volcano in Iceland.
And we saw the price of gas
spike like $0.40 in many
states a few months ago, just
because of one refinery fire
that was, I'm sure, thousands of
miles away from most of the
people affected
I think there's lots of evidence
now that the stuff
happening half a world away
really does affect your life
on a day to day basis.
I guess the better question is,
is there so much happening
that there's really no hope
that the well-informed lay
person like you or me can
actually understand the
financial situation in China
well enough to make wise
decisions based on that,
so why bother?
I don't have a better
rebuttal for that.
I'm afraid we're getting to the
point where that is true.
And does democracy have less
value in a world where a voter
really can't be well informed
about all the important issues
that matter?
I don't know.
It's an interesting question.
Yeah, go ahead?
AUDIENCE: So thank
you for coming.
I actually remember watching
your historic run on
"Jeopardy" with my roommate
at the time.
We would tune in every day and
watch and kind of like hope
that we're going to watch the
day that Ken Jennings gets
defeated, finally.
KEN JENNINGS: So let me
get this straight.
I've got like the best
job I've ever had.
I'm making like $50K an
hour or something.
And yet kids all over college
campuses, all over America,
are hoping I get fired.
AUDIENCE: We were fascinated,
yeah every day.
I remember there was like an
internet rumor that today was
the day that Ken lost.
And then the H&R Block question
came up and we were
like no way, he knows this.
KEN JENNINGS: So not only are
you hoping I lose, you thought
it was a super easy question?
AUDIENCE: Well, to
be fair, we did.
Anyway my question is, I've
always wondered this, does
Alex Trebek actually know the
answers to the questions?
KEN JENNINGS: Alex?
You know, it's funny.
I think "Jeopardy" is really,
the core viewership is college
students and old people.
I get the feeling nobody with
a job actually watches
"Jeopardy." And it's great
because the fact that the
audience skews to old means
that I don't get
recognized any more.
Most of the people who saw me
on the show are now dead or
they graduated.
Alex is a smart guy.
He's a big reader.
I've talked to him.
And he hosts the National
Geographic Bee.
And that's because he's
a true believer.
He's got a basement full of
"National Geographic"s going
back 50 years.
And basically he's your grandpa
watching History
Channel documentaries
about World War II.
He's a smart guy.
When people ask him that, he
says back in the day I could
have run the table.
I could have held my own in
"Jeopardy." But it's a young
man's game.
And I'm past my prime now.
So I think Alex feels he has
missed his chance at
"Jeopardy" starting.
Instead he gets to look like
a genius and be like
oh no, no, I'm sorry.
It's, what, is Tajikistan,
as if he knew?
And he'll do the phony
pronunciations too.
He'll be like, what
is Nicaragua?
He loves doing the foreign
pronunciations.
I think he's a smart guy.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was curious.
So I have an awful memory.
I was wondering if you've got
any memorization techniques
that you use?
KEN JENNINGS: People
ask me that a lot.
And I feel bad, but I
don't have a trick.
But I don't have a method or
an ancient Chinese herb or
whatever it would take for me
to write a self-help book or
make a billion dollars
on this.
I read a book about
trivia nerds.
And what I found out is that
most of these people
apparently came out of
the box that way.
There's something chromosomal
that makes some people
information sponges,
almost from birth.
Nothing you can do about it.
And I think it's relatable.
I mean we all are this way about
the things that we love.
You take some kid that's
terrible in school, but he
knows every word of every song
on his favorite album.
He knows every stat of his
favorite athlete or team, even
if he doesn't know
his times tables.
So it seems to me that interest
is the key thing that
makes people either able to
remember stuff or not.
If you care, you'll remember
it without even trying.
If you don't, almost no amount
of effort will get
it to stay in there.
And these trivia people tend
to be interested in
everything.
They're just curious
people by nature.
And I guess this sort of goes
to what I saying about the
utility of information.
Because they are curious about
everything, they'll find that
their knowledge has
a social utility.
They find it easier to
meet new people.
They'll sit next to somebody on
a plane and they'll be like
oh, you're from Fargo?
Do you know that baseball
player, Roger
Maris was from Fargo?
Have you ever been to the
Roger Maris museum?
The fact that they have this
wealth of seemingly useless
facts actually, bizarrely makes
it very easy for them to
get to know people.
But getting back to your
question, I feel like when I
was studying for "Jeopardy,"
there were things I tried to
cram on and I just
did terribly.
Like I had to memorize all the
presidents and their dates.
That's a "Jeopardy" stand by.
I had know cocktails.
I don't drink.
But "Jeopardy" always has
the "potent potable."
So I have all these
flashcards.
I had two sets of flashcards.
One have the presidents
on the front and the
dates on the back.
And the other had like on the
front it would be like, Harvey
Wallbanger.
And the back it would be like,
whatever is in a Harvey Wall--
I don't even know, vodka,
orange juice.
It's like a screwdriver with
Galliano or something.
Is that right?
Who's like a functioning
alcoholic?
Yeah, there you go.
So for weeks, all we would talk
about in our house was
like the presidency and
cocktails, presidency.
It's like going to college with
George W. Bush, I imagine.
But thank you for laughing at my
very cheap political joke,
cheap and out-of-date
political joke.
But I found the same
thing you did.
When these things were not
interesting to me, they were
incredibly hard to remember.
And I would make up a little
mnemonic stories, like I'm
sure you do for hard
to remember facts.
Like I had a hard time
remembering that John Quincy
Adams was elected in
1824, for example.
So I had to like make up this
very circuitous story in my
head about Quincy, the 1970s,
late '70s, early '80s, TV
medical examiner, working
a 24 hour shift.
OK, Quincy working
I can picture that.
1984, or 1824, John Quincy
Adams, for some reason that
would help me.
And these things were always
more complicated than the fact
I was trying to remember.
But something about them was
more helpful to me than the
fact itself.
And there are techniques
that you can do.
I mean have you heard about
this memory palace stuff?
The part of our brain that does
geography is very good.
So if you need to remember
a bunch of facts in order
quickly, you set up this mental
geography where you
wander through your childhood
house and you place the memory
sparking objects in a certain
order within the house.
And there are people who can
use techniques like this to
memorize all 52 cards in a deck
as fast as a dealer can
turn them over.
Like the guy will get done with
the deck and the person
can then recite the deck by
re-walking through the place
in his head.
And these are people with
ordinary memories, but they've
trained themselves to do
this parlor trick.
So yes, there are
parlor tricks.
And I'm terrible at them, I
guess is the short answer?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thanks are coming.
Like you, I grew up in a
pre-Google world of Birnbaum's
books and--
KEN JENNINGS: They're
old, huh?
AUDIENCE: And Poundstone and
the "Book of Lists." And
you've just published a book
of myths and trivia like
these, in that tradition.
Watson clearly demonstrates
that parsing and searching
structured knowledge, that
someone has structured,
[INAUDIBLE]
has structured for them, is
possible and can be made
mechanical.
There's still the thing that
Birnbaum does, that
mythologists do, that people
who discover new facts and
structure them.
Given that you've just published
this book, could you
speak a bit about that
and where that's
going in the future?
Because there are more facts
being produced in
more ways every day.
We all know, we work
at Google.
What are your thoughts
on that?
KEN JENNINGS: I mean this book
almost is sort of a throwback.
I mean a lot of this stuff in
this book, it was published in
academic journals.
These questions are
less googleable
than you'd think today.
But many of them, all it would
take is a parent visiting
Snopes or Wikipedia and they're
going to see the pros
and cons of all these.
But it's a good point.
When they talk about Watson as
a diagnostician for example,
in Watson's new health care
adventures, yes it's going to
be very good at recommending--
you get a list of symptoms and
it'll recommend treatments and
pharmaceutical possibilities
and suggest diagnoses.
But it's not going to be
doing original work.
It's not going to find
the new drug that
will treat these things.
It'll just tell a doctor which
of these three options you
already knew about, is
mathematically slightly more
likely in this case.
And that's the same thing
it was doing when it was
answering "Jeopardy"
questions too.
If you watched the show, you
could see the little
probability meter at the
bottom of its screen.
Sometimes it would make
incredibly naive errors.
In the category of US cities, it
would say, what is Toronto?
Realizing that even though
some pattern-matching had
worked, it had missed the most
important detail of all, that
a human never would have missed,
which is that Toronto
is not part of the US
until we invade it.
But yeah, that distinction
still remains.
I think a lot of lay people
would watch what Watson is
doing and give it a little
too much credit.
Wow, it understood
the question.
And it didn't really
understood.
It just could, in parallel,
weigh billions or trillions of
textual relationships in a very
efficient and smart way.
Now, what's interesting is that
it could do that and get
as good of results as a human,
doing what I would consider
high-level work.
So, we'll see.
But the creative part of those
jobs is still around.
When Trebek got asked about
this, he'd always say I'm not
worried until Watson can host
"Jeopardy." I don't care if it
can win "Jeopardy," I just
wondering whether
or not it can host?
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious about your
relationship with your
son with respect to facts
for instance.
I think all of us probably
grow up pre-Wikipedia.
So my relationship with my
father was very much, he was
the source of truth for many,
many years, until he stopped
being the source
for any truth.
And he did a pretty good job.
He's a very smart guy and
he's trivia focused.
He kicked our ass in "Trivial
Pursuit" for years.
And I grew up in--
KEN JENNINGS: I think you dad is
trivia focused by the way.
Like, that'll be on
his grave stone.
AUDIENCE: His resume, yeah.
So once Wikipedia came up, I
sort of like fact-checked
things when they came up.
I'm like where do I know that?
I think my dad just
made that up.
And he was right.
He was a pretty admirable job.
But now you can do that
from the age of five.
So you can't get away with just
pulling something out of
your ass when your son asks,
as my dad did fairly
successfully for 16 years.
So how has that changed
for you?
You have a unique perspective.
KEN JENNINGS: Are
you a parent?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm not.
KEN JENNINGS: Because when you
have kids you realize it's
another volume problem.
You can't keep up with the
volume of why questions.
And every time you answer a why
question with a "because,"
there'll be another
well, why that?
So you just get a higher level
thing and it becomes an
endless recursive.
I like to think that I'm pretty
good at saying I don't
know, let's look it up, as
opposed to, I'll just make up
for you how rainbows work.
Why not?
How are you going to
know any better?
But the temptation is certainly
there, because it
takes longer.
It takes longer to look
it up and explain it.
There's a "Calvin & Hobbes"
cartoon where Calvin asks his
dad why pictures are
black and white?
And his dad says that's how
the world used to be then.
Those are color photos of a
world that was black and white
before you were born.
And kids would we
believe that.
But at some point,
they're going to
realize that's not true.
This is the first Christmas
where neither of my kids
believes in Santa, so it's
very sad for us.
But yeah, I do feel
like the right
response is, I don't know.
Let's look it up.
Rather than ahh, stop
bugging me.
Let me just tell you
something short.
AUDIENCE: So he still
comes to you before
seeking it out himself?
KEN JENNINGS: He
actually does.
And I like to think
that's laziness.
It's like the upside of the
lazy computer for our
generation, is that as easy as
it is to do something online,
like asking the person there in
front of you is easier than
going to the computer and having
to type something in.
That feels like homework.
In fact, it is homework because
these kids are getting
assigned to answer these
questions with Google.
And so they don't see
this as fun anymore.
So I guess that was very clever
of teachers to make it
seem boring to actually have to
look stuff up, so that they
still need their parents.
That was good.
Thank you.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
First of all I wanted to state
for the record, I also
followed you when you were
historical in on "Jeopardy."
And I was rooting for you.
KEN JENNINGS: Well, that's
what we need.
AUDIENCE: It was reassuring,
that $75K run-away at the end.
So my question actually
was about the show.
It seems like there are multiple
shows taped per day.
So I was just curious a little
bit about that, logistics?
And given your long run, how
many times did you have to go
shopping in California?
KEN JENNINGS: The logistics in
"Jeopardy" are interesting.
What's the time on these.
Is this the last question or,
do this and one more?
OK.
If you're a fan of the show, you
might get the wrong idea
about how it works.
Alex will come out every day and
pretend it's a new show.
But really, they do
five in a day.
So a full week's worth of
shows is an afternoon.
And that's a long afternoon.
Dick Clark I understand used to
do 10 shows of "Pyramid,"
every day, which
blows my mind.
Because I got so exhausted after
doing five "Jeopardys."
So you show up in the morning,
get an orientation.
They sort of walk you through
the tricky "Jeopardy" buzzer
and what to do when you're on
stage, and don't freeze up,
and let's rehearse
your anecdotes.
Believe it or not, they do
rehearse those terrible
anecdotes they tell all
about their cats.
And I guess I shouldn't say
they, we tell about our cats.
But as soon as the game is over,
the contestants come
down stage.
There's this little awkward
chat down stage, which is
really a terrible
social dynamic.
Because two of you have
just lost, seen your
lifelong dream shattered.
One of you has just realized he
or she is going to go back
and do the whole thing again in
like 10 minutes, as soon as
you put on your tie or skirt.
And the fourth one of you just
wants to get out of there in
time because he's got
Laker tickets.
Alex is always in a hurry.
And as soon as they say
we're clear, you
get hustled off stage.
The losers have to sign a piece
of paper accepting their
consolation prizes.
The winner and Alex get hustled
off to change their
jacket, different dressing
rooms mind you.
And as soon as you got a new
tie, you come right back on,
it's like, "on yesterday's
show."
The real hitch for me was they
tape like three or four months
in advance.
So if you think about it, that's
not normally awkward.
Somebody can be on the show,
they can either choose whether
or not to tell their friends
how they did.
And then a few months later,
they have a big viewing party
and everybody cheers
or whatever.
In my case, my show started
airing while I was still on.
So I had 42 shows in the can
before one even aired--
or 38?
I think 38 shows in
the can before the
first one even aired.
So I was having to keep this
ever more momentous secret.
I was having to fly back
secretly from Salt Lake, where
we lived, down to LA,
twice a month.
Stay there for 48 hours, win,
as it turned out, 10
"Jeopardy" games at a head.
Fly back.
My boss was covering
for me at work.
She was only one who knew.
I hadn't told anybody else,
except my wife.
My boss covered for
me at work.
I'd fly back.
And she'd tell everybody oh,
Ken's son was sick or Ken is
painting his basement
or whatever.
If you think like computer
programmers are smart, yeah,
nobody ever figured it out.
And I'd have to come back to
work the next day and like
pretend I cared about
the morning
staff meeting or whatever.
You feel like you have
a secret identity.
You're jetting off to do
something glamorous.
I mean you got to come back to
the Daily Planet and be like,
Lois, Superman was here?
I can't believe I
missed it again.
It really did start to become
very confusing.
You start to have the Spiderman
problem of all the
little lies you have to tell.
If your parents call, you have
to pretend you're at home and
not on the 405 driving to Culver
City to do a game show.
And you don't have enough
changes of clothes,
so what do you do?
How do you get a sitter for the
kids, if my wife wanted to
come out and watch a show?
Do we do even have enough money
in the bank to cover
like the hotel?
Because "Jeopardy" does
not cover your travel
arrangements.
You fly out there on
your own dime.
So yeah, it got logistically,
surprisingly complicated.
And it was a relief when I could
actually sort of tell
what was going on.
I didn't have enough clothes.
I was a computer programmer.
Like I don't have like 75
changes of business casual.
Like if I wore the shorts
without the ketchup stain,
that's like dressing up.
So my brother is a lawyer
and he knew.
He and his wife had been
in the audience on
the very first game.
So they knew what
was going on.
So I would just borrow-- we're
about the same size.
So he would lend me clothes.
And really, you can rotate the
same cheap, JC Penney's
clothes, over and over
on "Jeopardy,"
and nobody ever notices.
That's what I learned.
I'd like to thank you all
for coming today.
It was a real pleasure.
If you want a book, I'll
be happy to sign
them, up there I gather.
But, thank you so much.